Matt Gates was call saying that the
Republicans were sending everybody home
to go cry about it that it's all about
one guy because they've uh recessed
until Tuesday which hopefully is good
for us for the event on Friday but
Matt's bent out of shape about it saying
they should they should be doing their
jobs and voting on a new speaker and
he's right I wonder what the point of a
recess is to be completely honest what's
what's the point well okay he's out now
we're going to go home no well why
wouldn't you just do your jobs these
people don't want to work yeah
politicians don't work they deal they're
professional thieves they're Liars
they're con artists and they're people
that should not be trusted with any kind
of Faith at all so uh with this news I I
think the more likely scenario I mean we
could all kind of speculate here and
talk about Trump being the speaker of
the house but the most likely scenario
here that's going to unfold is that
there's probably going to be a lot more
infighting there probably won't be a
speaker of the house and because of that
there's going to be stagnation in
Washington DC and that to me is a
beautiful thing